[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
football rivalry an unexpected Victory
then an unspeakable tragedy as a match
between Indonesian sides arima FC and
persebaya Surabaya in the city of Malang
Drew to a close arima's fans who'd just
seen their side lose this fixture for
the first time in 23 years ran onto the
pitch
[Applause]
clashed with police
players too were reportedly attacked
amid the chaos police fired tear gas
that in turn caused Panic then a
Stampede in which scores of people were
crushed to death Indonesian authorities
have claimed the stadium was over
capacity
[Applause]
the police had already taken
preventative action before finally
firing the tear gas because the
supporters were already attacking the
police and burning vehicles
after police fired the tear gas they all
ran towards the same direction to exit
gate number 10 and 12 causing a massive
Jam during the jam shortness of breath
occurred because they were running out
of oxygen
the death toll already makes it one of
the world's most deadly football
tragedies and officials say many more
victims are seriously injured in
hospital
I regret this tragedy and I hope this is
the last football tragedy in this
country a tragedy like this must not
happen anymore in the future
[Applause]
Indonesia has seen violence at football
matches before but nothing quite like
this
the league is now suspended a nation is
in shock and soon they will need an
explanation for how and why it came to
this
Matthew Thompson Sky News